bill Plunkett bill covers the Dodgers
for the Orange County Register and he
joins us from spring training first of
all bill thanks for joining us on short
notice
how serious are the Dodgers and they're
offered to Bryce Harper oh I think
they're serious but they're serious on
their terms this the way they operate
under Andrew Friedman's they do not get
into bidding wars and I don't think they
are anywhere near a 10-year 300 million
dollar interest I think they're there
their strategy all along was to stay
engaged stay involved and kind of lurk
on the perimeter and if a ten-year 300
million dollar you know market didn't
develop that they were willing to get
creative at a shorter term contract you
know six years maybe with a couple opt
outs for years for 150 so you can so
Boris can say he got him the highest
annual average salary spin it that way I
think that's always been their strategy
and I don't think the the meeting Sunday
changed that at all
and I'm wondering if Bryce Harper wakes
up and realizes gosh I might have to
play in Philadelphia where he probably
didn't think he was going to be playing
into Philadelphia bill that's exactly
what this comes down to does he want the
ten years and the 300 million plus if it
means going to Philly or is he willing
to take a shorter shorter deal a more
creative contract and play the place
that he wants to play you know is it is
it money you're gonna get plenty of
money both ways or is it location and
you know I don't know quality of life I
guess you call it if you talk about a
guy who's from Vegas
you know he's four hours away in LA a
lot less by private jet he's pretty
close obviously from Camelback Ranch
here they you know again private jet
gets you back to him from Vegas pretty
quick so I think he's made it clear that
his preference is the West Coast and on
the west coast his ideal spot would be
the Dodgers so does that outweigh the 10
year commitment and security and
the you know being able to say you got a
bigger contract and the chato wouldn't
Stanton you know I think honestly I
think it's in his court what what do you
value more but I think that both sides
can save face I'm talking about Bryce
Harper in Scott Boras Scott Boras can
get what he wants to say look at the
yearly salary I got you and that you
have Bryce Harper getting to the Dodgers
getting to the West Coast which I
believe he wants to I think that's what
you're saying yeah exactly and in on the
shorter term deal you can still take him
out on the free agent market again and
at say age 30 and Bryce Harper at age 30
you would think would still be in his
prime years and you know if you commit
to Philly and you don't get opt-outs
you're looking at 36 before you have a
chance to change things or if you do get
opt outs why you know why take a I think
somebody phrased it as why get into a
marriage that you're gonna you know
regret and want a divorce in four years
or just take the four years at a place
you want to play and then deal with it
at age thirty what's the timeframe for
all of this I don't think it's very
clear I think he wants to I think in
Indiana in Bryce's mind there's probably
a clock ticking to March first that just
seems like a logical place to say I need
to be in camp somewhere by March 1st if
I'm gonna be ready for opening day I
don't think either you know any of the
sides have set any deadlines and said we
need an answer but I I just have a
feeling we're gonna this is gonna reach
conclusion in the next you know three or
four days Wow talking to Bill Plunkett
he covers the Dodgers Orange County
Register the bigger pressing issue is
your starting pitcher Clayton Kershaw
how serious is yeah concern here I think
it's got to be getting pretty serious
now I mean this is a guy who let's be
honest the last 3-4 years has had his
share of physical problems and then he
shows up in tamp it throws two times and
is having problems with his shoulder and
that's not that's got to be pretty
elevated level of concern around here
especially when
was pitched to us last week when he
stopped throwing that it was just an
early spring thing a few days off any
inflammatories he'll pick up a ball
he'll be fine and then he picks up a
ball plays you know like game of catch
and the shoulder isn't better so the
thing that surprises me is they haven't
sent the guy for an MRI I would think
that you would want some answers about
what's going on in there maybe they
don't want to know but but how I gotta
believe that he was working out in the
offseason and maybe you give the Dodgers
a heads up that ya got some soreness
here tightness here inflammation here
everything every indication is that
there was nothing going on until let's
see where motel we could go Monday we
could go yesterday he threw a bullpen
session didn't feel right that was the
phrase that kept using went into a
batting cage area where we can't watch
through some more to try and work
through it
two days later he scheduled the throw to
hitters live batting practice he does he
looks okay yeah there was nothing
visually alarming but that was the one
where he he told him he didn't feel
right and he hasn't picked up a ball
since then other than play catcher
achievements all right these next couple
days gonna be interesting about the the
future there with Bryce Harper and well
if they whip on Harper and Kershaw is a
little more serious here boy oh boy I
will I will say this they have a deeper
group of starting pitchers and it is
anybody in baseball so they can absorb
it if it means he can't start the season
misses a month and he's missed you know
like five weeks at a time each of the
last three years with the back injuries
so they can absorb it but it does
obviously impacts the front of the
rotation it's not just a depth issues
it's a guy that you planned on starting
on opening day man bill thank you we
appreciate your time that's bill
Plunkett it covers Dodgers kind of
depressing if you're not a fan or
serious I know I know four more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]